hey guys how's it goin I'm just seeing
welcome back to cooking with Justine
that's me today we're gonna make a red
velvet cake with cheesecake icing and
we're gonna make it some scratch I have
a box here already mixed red velvet cake
but I was like nope
whoo easy so it's not a recipe on the
internet so if I'm looking off to the
side here it's getting doing I'm looking
at what the hell is this two cups of
flour yeah
all-purpose what's your purpose sir oh
[Music]
let's just make way here one two
aching soda line up baking soda I got
baking soda baking soda baking powder I
got baking powder I got picking powder
teaspoon that's the little one okay
baking powder one teaspoon
yeah that looks good I like the way you
do me like that like that 1 teaspoon of
salt 2 tablespoons of unsweetened cocoa
powder 2 there's some things that I
ain't about measuring is one of us one
cup might be a little more that's a lot
of sugar this is not good for you hmm
that's definitely way more than a cup 1
cup of vegetable oil things are going
well things are going really well
actually that's a lot of vegetable oil I
don't think this is very good for you
1 cup of buttermilk also not like this
is not healthy
I wonder if I'm supposed to do this in
like a certain order oh boy yeah this is
not right it's saying I'm supposed to do
a lot of stuff separately and then put
them all in together but that's not
clearly not happening here when do you
expect the whole friggin egg
alright well two tips one I think that
was like - this was nice hey let's make
a red velvet cake but you need two
coloring because a lot actually red are
you health conscious don't come here
it's gonna look like friggin Dexter just
perked up in here mine why have two
sugars that was a lot a teaspoon 1/2 cup
of prepared plain hot coffee get out of
here ok and prepared for the brew
[Music]
half cup oh gosh
making a mess that was more than half
which is very unfortunate because I
wanted to drink it just blend this
together and see what happens I don't
know what's gonna happen here we go
wishes luck let's give it a nice little
mix around you look alright it's not
drop open up shop you're the Rough
Riders whoa I have more food in my hair
than I think I have inside of this
container right now
I thought the pan was going to be twice
this size how do I flour it where I just
throw flour on it I feel like I saw my
mom do this when I was little
she'd go like that and then she'd go
like this this looks good I think I did
a good job so let's put this into the
oven what did you say
middle rack okay looking good you look
like a little Anya or something so while
our cake is cooking for however many
minutes it's supposed to be cooking I'm
gonna make the icing 1/2 a cup of butter
I'm gonna soften this cream cheese to 8
ounce packages 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
here's the problem we need 2 of these
mistakes were made
oops oops I said on mine didn't really
mean to say on my I'm done she will just
leave the butter 2 cups sifted I ain't
sifting nothing 2 cups how many cups are
in here like what's what is okay look
I'm sifting sift it like it's hot
sift it like it's hot looks like two
cups to me this is my first time ever
using cream cheese before I misread my
directions this is just not right
first of all why would anybody ever do
this why would anyone ever do this ever
I'm gonna keep asking myself this I'm
just creaming it together I'm missing a
whole stick of cream cheese this can't
be good like this is disgusting you just
take a little pink
it looks like scrambled eggs I made a
mistake guys this is not good no
starting to rise up over top of this
shoot mistakes have been made again and
then we have this like this does not
look good
[Music]
some things happened while the camera
was not on as you guys may recall I
placed the cake in between two racks
homeboy let's take a peek
what happened since you've been gone
we had to have an emergency wrap
extraction so as you can see here this
is the rack racks on racks you do not
work out so well you look awful actually
we also had a problem with the icing if
you recall it's chunky make do with what
you've got
[Music]
hey why not why not ice to cake with a
soup ladle this is all of God this is
all I've got so sorry Martha
Rachael Ray anyone who knows how to cook
where's my cake hey should I cut it all
right why not
here we go nice little slice I think
I'll take a piece from the middle look
at it oh my gosh it's so Billy in the
middle for as much crap as I have messed
up this tastes delicious do you know why
this is not good for you I am going into
cardiac arrest right now buddy call
9-1-1 my arteries are clogging on the
dance floor
whoa thanks so much for watching this
was making a red velvet cheesecake icing
cake from scratch and surprisingly if
you followed the recipe maybe a little
bit closer than I did you might actually
turn out with something fantastic so
make sure you guys like this video and
be sure to subscribe subscribe to my
channel so you can see more videos when
I post them I'm gonna go save a piece of
this for my sister and see what she
thinks
oh no I'm actually gonna do a giveaway
this awesome glass 3d sketched creation
I'm sure what to call